دعنا نحضر رئيس منظمة أوبك في
مجال الطاقة داعم إنتل أمينة ،
دعونا فقط نضع الأمور في نصابها الصحيح
حيث موقف الإمارات والسعودية
من حيث الطاقة الإنتاجية الفائضة
بيكي أعتقد أن الرئيس ماكرون
أساء فهم الرسالة التي
نقلها إليه رئيس الإمارات العربية المتحدة وكان هذا
الارتباك  واضح جدًا في الفيديو
أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، قال إن الإمارات العربية المتحدة قد
تجاوزت طاقتها القصوى في الواقع ،
تحافظ الإمارات على
حصتها الإنتاجية من أوبك زائد والتي تبلغ حوالي
3.16 مليون برميل يوميًا ، وتبلغ الطاقة الإجمالية لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
4.2 مليون برميل
يوميًا.  لا يزال لديهم طاقة
فائضة الآن عندما يتعلق الأمر بالمملكة العربية السعودية ،
ما قاله الرئيس ماكرون هو أنه لا
يمكنهم سوى زيادة 150 ألف برميل
يوميًا وهذا غير صحيح مرة أخرى ،
فإن حصة المملكة العربية السعودية بموجب النظام الجديد تبلغ
حوالي 10.8 وقدرتها الإجمالية هي
12  مليون برميل في اليوم لذلك بين
الإمارات العربية المتحدة والمملكة العربية السعودية أود أن أقول إن
هناك حوالي 2.1 إلى 2.2 مليون برميل
يوميًا من الطاقة الاحتياطية
الأجنبية هناك  في ذهنك كان هذا
مجرد ارتباك
من جانب الرئيس أو
كان هناك شيء آخر يلعب هنا
أعتقد أنه فقط انطلاقا من تعبير
أه عن الرئيس ماكارا وكيف
تم نقل الرسالة يمكنني القول
إنها كانت أه كانت  مجرد ارتباك من
جانبه لا يفهم كيف
يتم حساب السعة الفائضة والسعة الفائضة
بالطبع أعني أننا رأينا مراقبين
والكثير من الأشخاص خاصة على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
يقولون إن هذا ربما كان مقصودًا
ولكن ما فعله بيكي هو
أهمية ما رأيناه  هنا فقط يعطينا
طعمًا لما ستبدو عليه أسواق النفط
إذا لم يكن لدينا طاقة احتياطية في
اللحظة التي قال فيها ماكرون إنه لا توجد
طاقة احتياطية ارتفعت الأسعار بنسبة 2 في
المائة.
كان المنتجون حذرين للغاية فيما
يتعلق بطاقتهم الفائضة
وكيفية استخدامهم لها مع التطلع إلى الأمام
ولهذا السبب نتوقع منهم أن يستمروا في
توخي الحذر بشأن كيفية استخدام السعة الاحتياطية